-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
everyone,
to "The Tonight Show."
We are here tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys,
I'm very excited about this.
The one and only Mariah Carey
is my guest here tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
We're kicking off the holiday
season on a very high note.
That's right.
By the way, you don't
just invite Mariah.
You have to say "Christmas"
three times
and she suddenly appears.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Mariah has been dubbed
the Queen of Christmas,
which explains why Mrs. Claus
just tweeted this.
Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And this is fun.
Mariah just released
her new children's book,
"The Christmas Princess."
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm happy for her,
but it stung
when my kids were like, "Now,
that's a children's book."
[ Audience "Awws" ]
"Say da, da. Say da da."
Yeah.
Well, it's going to be a fun
weekend here in New York City
because this Sunday
is the New York City marathon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's this weekend.
Is anyone here
running the marathon?
-Yeah!
-Yeah?
[ Applause ]
I'm sure
that won't be the last time
we hear you're running
the marathon.
[ Laughter ]
Good luck for you, by the way.
A little trivia for you.
I heard that the fastest
marathon runners
can hit a top speed
of almost 13 miles an hour.
[ Audience murmurs ]
Then everyone
who drives a Kia Sportage
was like, "Big deal, so can we."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
people from all over the world
are competing in this marathon,
and it's very interesting --
the city is adding some new
obstacles along the route
to give runners the full
New York experience.
I'll show you what I mean.
In Times Square...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
Down in Staten Island...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Over in Washington Square
Park...
[ Laughter and applause ]
At this point...
[ Laughter ]
As they go up
near Central Park...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Right over here...
[ Applause ]
Very cheap.
Also at this point...
And finally,
once they finish the race...
There you go.
The runners will.
Good luck to everyone
running the marathon.
Meanwhile,
early on Sunday morning,
Daylight Savings Time ends.
So, you'll gain an hour.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
At 2:00 a.m.,
all the clocks turn back an hour
while every bartender
lets out an audible sigh.
Whew! [ Sighs ]
Well, let's get to some news.
With midterms
just a few days away,
former President Trump is going
on a final campaign blitz.
At a rally last night in Iowa,
Trump hinted that he's
going to run again in 2024,
but he did it in
a pretty odd way.
Watch this.
-I will very, very, very
probably do it again, okay?
Very, very, very probably.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ As Trump ] It's like my
favorite book,
"The Very, Very, Very Probably
Hungry Caterpillar."
[ Laughter ]
Very, very, very, very,
probably.
[ Applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
It's also how Trump
recited his wedding vows.
[ As Trump ] I very, very,
very probably do.
[ Laughter ]
Some more news on the midterms.
Oprah, who launched
Dr. Oz's career,
just endorsed his opponent,
John Fetterman.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Apparently, this year, one of
Oprah's favorite things is...
betrayal.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Oprah endorsed Fetterman,
which explains why Dr. Oz
just tweeted this.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Oz and Fetterman,
during last night's
World Series game,
I don't know if you saw this,
I noticed that ads
for the two candidates
aired back-to-back.
And the timing was pretty great.
Check this out.
-Together, we'll stand up
to extremism on both sides
and bring balance to Washington.
I'm Dr. Oz.
I approve this message.
-Oz is a piece of [bleep]
in my opinion.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dr. Oz was like,
"The proper medical term is
piece of stool sample."
[ Laughter ]
Well, a lot of people
are talking about this.
Jeff Bezos
is thinking about buying
the Washington Commanders.
Did you see that? Yeah.
Well, yeah, this guy
might become an NFL owner.
So we decided
to ask some NFL players
if they want to play for Bezos,
and here's what they said.
First, Trevor Lawrence
from the Jaguars said...
And Brendan Schooler
from the Patriots said...
Next, Andrew Van Ginkel
from the Dolphins said...
Then Billy Price
from the Cardinals said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next, Lane Johnson
from the Eagles said...
Then Brian Hoyer
from the Patriots said...
And finally, Las Vegas Raiders
owner Mark Davis said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, get this.
The M.T.A. just released
a new subway bingo game
to make riding the train
a fun experience.
[ Laughter ]
The M.T.A. said, "Well,
it's the least we could do."
And New Yorkers were like,
"Clearly."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, the bingo card has things
like escalator, wooden bench,
and business man getting kicked
in the face by a break dancer.
It's fun.
Well, hey, I saw this
for the holidays,
Miller Lite is releasing
a pretty wild contraption.
Take a look at this.
-Beer brand Miller Lite
is releasing
a Christmas tree keg stand
this holiday season.
Its fully functioning tree stand
is designed to fit around
a quarter-barrel keg.
Its design makes it seem
like beer is being poured
from the tree.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ I'm dreaming
of a white trash Christmas ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you thought the Christmas
tree was lit before...
Yeah.
Kids will be like,
"I saw Mommy
dragging Santa Claus
to the couch."